boat ramps and low water levels at lake
mead are forcing people to look for
other boating options this memorial day
weekend mary jane belliesa is at willow
beach in arizona with reaction
it's a packed saturday at willow beach
many people driving an hour or more to
take advantage of the warm weather and
to hit the water as lake mead remains
down to one boat ramp this memorial day
weekend one las vegas local didn't want
to take a chance we've heard a lot of
good things about willow beach my
biggest concern was the fact that the
launches are all closed there's only one
open for lake mead and the lines are
probably insane
the water levels are obviously
concerning as well i just figured it's
going to be a lot busier out there
catherine pastor and her husband troy
made the drive from flagstaff arizona
she says lake powell is also drying up
it is concerning about the water levels
between our two states and what we're
going to do about it and
i think you know we always try to figure
out how to conserve and that piece but
we're also trying to use our natural
resources with several boat ramps closed
in lake mead national park service
anticipates more people to come to
willow beach this weekend and for the
summer troy pastor says with more people
outdoors it's important to be aware of
the fire and boating restrictions so if
you remember last year at this time i
think they closed down at least in
arizona they closed down the forest
before memorial day because of the fire
situation
so i hate to be that guy to say it but
we don't want somebody to leave a
campfire to leave something out and then
the wind this wind out here right now
takes it away water is an essential
function of being able to live
and so those are the pieces that
awareness i think is the number one key
but then also action mary jane balliosa
live local now